oh we're about to talk about some
multiverse of madness but first i want
to thank the sponsor of this video this
video is brought to you by display
because the quest for a perfect nerd
cave is a quest worth doing display
offers high quality prints on metal with
millions of options available video
games comic books movies comic book
movies my spirit animal and displaying
them is really easy just wipe down the
wall stick the magnet the print hangs
right there and in a world where we just
got to change it up sometimes swapping
out the prints is easy as one two and
that's it there's no three it's one two
done so click the link below and for a
limited time you get 31 off of one or
two prints or 41 off of three or more
prints go well traveler and optimizing
your nerd room and now the moment you've
all been waiting for that moment right
thank you for clicking on my face thank
you for that i feel the love you're the
best also this is a spoiler free review
that is to say there are no spoilers in
this video i do plan on making a spoiler
talk video in the next couple days or so
keep your eye out for that in the
meantime let's get strange
[Music]
so doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness is a new doctor strange movie
the new mcu movie dr stephen strange
runs across a girl named america chavez
he's like i'm gonna help this girl i'm
gonna protect her because there are
nefarious things after her and that
adventure takes them through the
multiverse
of madness now the dynamic between
doctor strange and america chavez i
really liked it it's kind of like you
know he wants to protect her she doesn't
really trust him but as i i don't know
much about america chavez i i'm
posturing i don't know anything about
her like i've said but i've said this
before and i will say it again we are in
the deep cuts of the marvel world my
friends we're in the deep cuts of the
comic book movie universe we are past
iron man and spider-man and the
incredible hulk and captain america and
things i knew more about i'm just
sitting back and relaxing and enjoying
the mcu as it comes at me at this point
point is as i don't know anything about
america chavez i did like the dynamic
between her and dr strain i thought it
was a good one i thought it was done
well also her name cracks me up and it
shouldn't but it's like every time
doctor strange would be like america
that song changed the course of history
don't let anyone tell you different or
my favorite i think it was strange was
like is america okay i was like no not
really no
oh you mean the kid yeah i'm sure she's
fine when is i like the dynamic between
doctor strange and her now this is sam
raimi in the mcu no he did not do any
well i guess technically
he did an mcu multiverse movie before it
was an mcu multiverse movie but for the
sake of technically being accurate this
is his first mcu movie as the mcu has
existed and he brings a sam raimi
dynamic man like the first 10 15 minutes
of this movie there's an action sequence
and i was like this is that this reminds
me of something just the way it was like
steven strange doctor strange going in
to save the day that's civilian to hero
dynamic when he gears down and then the
action sequence as it was filmed as it
looked it was just very reminiscent of
the action sequence one of the action
sequences in spider-man 2. gotta say i
was like i'm in it works for me man call
it nostalgic call it whatever but i
liked it also does this movie have
horror elements in it we've seen him
interject horror elements into like
spider-man 2. when doc ock is in the or
he becomes doctor octopus and those
metal arms just like horror movie snakes
killing everybody that's like a horror
movie scene in a comic book movie but
the rest of the movie doesn't feel too
horror movie s this movie has a lot of
horror movie tones sprinkled throughout
and it weirdly works it works because
you're going through the multiverse
different realms different realities and
sometimes it doesn't explain how or why
a thing works it just works sometimes
that does work for the movie sometimes
it's like no you didn't hide it enough i
get it you're just kind of hoping that
everyone's like yeah but it looks cool
did it look cool yeah but i just kind of
wasn't blinded for that moment so now
i'm questioning it so there's give and
take there but the point is when it's
sam raimi horror tone it was awesome i
liked that more than the concept of
going through the multiverse i just any
time it was sam raimi horror tone it was
like this is badass and kind of in line
with that you know what i like most
about this movie and i mean it
the carnage that's right new mcu movie
what did i like most the blood the
slaughter i mean it you can have horror
tone without blood you can have blood
with that heart i mean it's not super
bloody i'm just saying more people died
horribly in this movie than i expected
to die so horribly in an mcu movie and
you know you feel like sam raimi's been
waiting for it he's probably out there
like when i took on spider-man they said
the world wasn't ready for this in a
family-friendly pg-13 superhero movie
but
the time is now what can i say i like me
some fun unexpected carnage candy and
i'm not i don't want to over hype it i
don't want to oversell it but i'm just
saying in doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness
it tasted pretty good you know who i
loved in this movie elizabeth olsen as
wanda maximoff yeah i thought she was
excellent in this movie granted she has
a lot of emotional setup and that
emotional setup from other mcu things
feeds into the emotional moments in here
and i thought she had a great emotional
arc i didn't cry but it kind of got the
knot in the throat going you know you
know how it is
but i didn't cry
pointy i thought she was great also the
musical score danny elfman does the
musical score
standout moments for the musical score
as well you ever watch a movie i've seen
this in the mcu more than a few times
where you watch movies like the movie's
great and your friend could be like yeah
what was your favorite part of the
musical score you'll be like
i don't know for nothing else there's a
thing that's just creatively interesting
that has to do with music in the end
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness was a bonkers batshit crazy
multiverse good time it doesn't always
stick to landing on things or some
moments where you're like yeah you're
just kind of aimlessly going places
aren't you and it doesn't really pay off
but it looks cool and you're just hoping
the audience
that's enough enough for the audience
they won't question it right and
sometimes yeah they get away with that
but when i left the movie i was like i
enjoyed that could have also been
shorter there were a couple of cheese
dialogue moments not necessarily
just
i can't limit it to the script it just
sounded like there were a couple of
moments where someone's trying to sound
very villainous but it came across as
cheesy i could totally see it sam raimi
just doing that like yeah cheese is fun
right it's not everywhere in the movie
so i'm not saying the whole movie's like
that those moments that it does happen
just stand out like
it's the best you got but for the most
part i had a really good time with this
movie it's when sam raimi injects that
sam raimi horror flavor into the mcu
that's when i felt this movie was in top
shape i don't even care oh it doesn't
fit with the rest of the mcu don't care
i thought that's when it was at its best
and i love the fact that as i'm talking
about this is like the first mcu movie i
can think of where i'm like well
i know your kids grew up with the mcu i
mean or are growing up with the mcu not
to say your kids are all grown up and
that's where this conversation comes
into play if you have really young kids
who like some of the nice lighter movies
of the mcu
there's some imagery in here it looks
great but also might terrify the [ __ ]
out of them and give them nightmares you
know your kids you do you you parent how
you parent i'm just saying i'm here to
inform and for me i thought this movie
was a great time no alcohol required and
again as i tried to keep this video
vague in the next couple days i'll
release the spoiler talk video where i
get into the spoilerish elements of
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness what's the doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness have you seen it
what did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]
you